[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers concitoyens américains
et pour ceux qui m'ont conduit ici
salutations aux gens du delaware je vois
à mon ami le sénateur il est là je pense
le sénateur koons et là je pense que les
gouverneurs l'entourent je pense est-ce
que séverine tel kelakh et
l'ex-gouverneur ma soeur valérie et ma
belle soeur gabin bon voilà chers
concitoyens le peuple américain a parlé
il nous a donné une victoire claire une
victoire convaincante
une victoire pour nous le peuple nous
avons remporté la victoire avec le plus
non plus grand nombre de votes de toute
l'histoire des états unis
74 millions de voix le plus grand nombre
de votes de notre histoire
je dois admettre que ça m'a surpris mais
ce soir je nous voyons partout tant la
nation toutes les villes toutes les
régions du pays et en fait même partout
sur la planète on voit qu'il y à un
monde en liesse les gens qui ont de
l'espoir et qui ont renouvelé leur
espoir en vue d' un nouveau jour qui
n'est aujourd'hui et ce sont des
témoignages de confiance envers moi je
j'ai prêté serment pour être président
non pas président de la division mais un
unificateur
il ne perçoit pas les états unis comme
des états rouge au bleu démocrates
républicains mais qui ne voit qu'un seul
pays les états unis d'amérique et je
vais travailler de tout coeur avec la
pleine confiance que me donne le peuple
et j'ai travaillé ainsi pour mériter
votre confiance
celle de tous et l'amérique d'après moi
sa nature et elle repose là-dessus
l'amérique et au sujet du peuple et mon
administration sera à l'administration
du peuple
cette administration sera maintenant ici
pour restaurer l'âme des ethnies pour la
classe moyenne pour pouvoir lui donner
une nouvelle chance pour que les états
unis d'amérique se respecter à nouveau
sur l'échiquier planétaire
c'est le grand honneur de ma vie d'être
ici il ya des millions tellement de
millions d'américains qui ont voté pour
cette vision ce qui me rend fier et
maintenant le travail réel commence pour
réfléter cette vision c'est la tâche de
notre époque comme je vous le dis
souvent à mes chers concitoyens à
plusieurs reprises je suis le mari de
jill biden
ma femme et je ne pourrai être ici au
podium sans son amour sans son plein
appui l'appui de ma femme jill et deux
filles de tous mes petits enfants de
routeurs et et de toute la grande
famille mais pour les épouses et c'est
gilles est une éducatrice
c'est une mère aussi elle s'est
consacrée à l'éducation
mais l'enseignement ce n'est pas quelque
chose qu'elle fait c'est qui elle est
les éducateurs les enseignants voyez
vous je vous le dis aujourd'hui est une
journée formidable pour vous vous aurez
votre enseignante à la maison blanche et
dubaï donne sera une formidable premier
dame première dame et je suis très fier
d'elle
[Musique]
j'ai venez d'entendre kamala harris qui
sera une première vice-présidente
américaine elle
c'est un moment d'histoire ce sera la
première vice présidente américaine
d'origine indienne et noir fille
d'immigrants d'origines et ados
jamaïcaine ne me dites pas que ces
choses là ne sont pas possibles aux
états unis cela devait arriver bien
avant
et ce soir on se rappelle à tous ceux
qui ont lutté si fort depuis tellement
d'années pour rendre ce moment possible
encore une fois les etats-unis penchent
de plus en plus vers la justice
câble a dog que vous l'aimiez ou non
votre famille donc vous devenez donc un
membre honoraire illégalement de la
famille grande famille ici tous ceux qui
ont été des bénévoles qui ont travaillé
dans les centres électoraux durant la
pandémie
les officiels on vous doit le plus grand
merci à mercy qui vient de toute la
nation
merci à mon équipe ma campagne mais
bénévole à tous ceux qui se sont
tellement consacré pour rendre ce moment
possible merci je vous dois je le répète
je vous dois un grand merci et à tous
ceux qui nous ont appuyés
je suis fier de la campine campagne que
nous avons mené de la coalition que nous
avons créé la coalition la plus
diversifiée de l'histoire des démocrates
des indépendants et des républicains à
des progressistes des conservateurs et
cetera des gens qui vivent dans les
villes
qu'ils vivent que des des latinos des
asiatiques des autochtones des premières
nations et c est donc il y a de ces
moments voyez-vous où la situation
n'allait pas très bien pour la campagne
mais encore une fois les afro américains
se sont levés vous m'avez toujours
défendu dans ces moments plus difficiles
et je vais toujours vous défendre j'ai
dit d'entrée de jeu que je voulais
représenter les états unis que la
campagne ressemble aux etats-unis nous
l'avons fait maintenant le moment est
venu pour que notre administration
puisse refléter les états unis pour tous
ceux qui ont voté pour le président
europe
je sais que vous êtes des à poitiers ce
soir je le comprends moi même j'ai perdu
plusieurs défaites moi même mais on va
tous se donner une chance si vous le
voulez bien
[Applaudissements]
le moment est venu de mettre de côté la
rhétorique dure de nous calmer de se
regarder à nouveau de s'écouter à
mauvais le moment est venu de réaliser
des progrès pour cela il faut arrêter de
traiter ceux qui s'opposaient contre
nous à nous comme des ennemis mais ce ne
sont pas des ennemis ce sont des
américains
la bible nous enseigne qu'il ya une
saison pour toute chose qui vient temps
pour construire un temps pour récolter
un temps pour semer et un temps pour
guérir
le moment est venu pour la guérison des
états unis
et maintenant cette campagne est
terminée alors la volonté du peuple
qu'elle est il qu'elle est notre mandat
je crois que notre mandat est le suivant
l'amérique nous a demandé d'opter pour
la décence pour la justice pour que nous
mettions de l'avant la science et pour
que nous faisons progresser l'espoir eu
égard aux grandes batailles auxquelles
nous faisons face la bataille contre le
virus la bataille pour reconstruire la
prospérité pour garantir que vos
familles accès à des soins de santé
la bataille de la justice pour éliminer
une fois pour toutes des racines et le
racisme systémique au pays
c'est une bataille pour sauver notre
planète en contrôlant le climat c'est
une bataille pour restaurer la décence
pour défendre la démocratie et pour
donner à tous citoyens à tout
concitoyens une chance c'est tout ce
qu'ils veulent les américains veulent
une chance de réussir et nous leur
donnerons cela notre travail commence
par une gestion de la coved
nous ne pouvons pas réparer l'économie
revitaliser l'économie relancer
l'économie et retrouver ces moments qui
sont tellement important pour nous les
différents moments de célébration
lorsqu'il ya des jeunes diplômés etc
auprès de nos familles si on ne résout
pas ce problème
les scientifiques les experts seront là
cette fois ci pour nous aider et nous
avons un plan
c'est le plan by day qui sera mise en
oeuvre c'est un plan pour lutter contre
la pandémie qui sera mise en oeuvre à
partir du 20 janvier un plan fondé sur
des données probantes la compassion
l'empathie se soucier des gens cela
aussi est important dans ce plan qui est
le nôtre nous n'allons pas il pas renié
des efforts
nous ferons tout en notre pouvoir pour
résoudre ce défi pandémique
je suis un démocrate et fier de l'être
cher concitoyen mais je vais gouverner
en tant que président des états unis je
vais travailler aussi fort pour ceux qui
n'ont pas voté pour moi que pour ceux
qui ont voté pour moi
alors que cette ère sombre de
démonisation de polarisation aux états
unis se termine à partir de maintenant
[Applaudissements]
les républicains démocrates refusent de
collaborer
ce n'est pas dû à une force mystérieuse
qui est au delà de notre contrôle
cela dépend d'un choix personnel que
nous faisons nous pouvons décider de ne
pas coopérer
si on peut le faire on peut décider de
travailler ensemble de coopérer et je
crois que ce moment cif
en fait ça fait partie du mandat qui est
exprimé par la voix du peuple le peuple
américain veut que nous collaborions
pour leur meilleur intérêt et c'est le
choix que je ferai et je vais demander
au congrès américain qu'il signifie
entre républicains démocrates que nous
fassions ce choix précis l'histoire
américaine repose sur des opportunités
de progrès lente et vaste trop de rêve
ont été remis à plus tard
trop souvent nous devons rendre le rêve
américain accessible à tous peu importe
la race le genre l'identité la fois où
le handicap
les américains doivent pouvoir accéder à
ce rêve
l'amérique a toujours été façonné par
des moments charnières des moments de
l'histoire important nous avons pris la
bonne décision relativement à notre
identité relativement à qui nous voulons
être renken 1860 à sauver l'union
roosevelt en 50 2 a fait son new deal
pour rebâtir le pays
kennedy en 1960 a donné ce rêve d'une
nouvelle frontière vers la lune et
barack obama il ya quelques années nous
a dit que vient ce week-end nous
pouvions réussir
chers concitoyens nous sommes un de ces
moments charnières nous avons ici une
opportunité de lutter contre le
désespoir et de reconstruire un pays de
prospérité nous pouvons le faire je le
sais j'ai souvent parlé de la lutte pour
sauver l'âme de l'amérique nous devons
restaurer l'âme retrouver l'âme de la
mairie tokyo nation est façonnée à même
ses lutte constante entre les anges du
bien et deux impulsions les plus basses
notre contribution personnelle est
important dans cette lutte
le moment est venu pour les anges du
bien de gagner la victoire
le monde entier regarde les états unis
ce soir et je crois que le monde et d'un
symbole un modèle pour le monde
nous allons mener par la puissance de
notre exemple et non pas par la
manifestation de notre pouvoir j'ai
toujours cru en cela beaucoup de gens
m'ont tendu le dire j'ai toujours cru
que nous pouvions définir l'amérique en
un seul mot par un seul mot les
possibilités aux états unis tout le
monde devrait avoir l'opportunité des
possibilités de afin de pouvoir réaliser
leur rêve et dieu leur a donné des
habiletés et nous pouvons les réaliser
nous avons toujours rêvé de états unis
des états unis plus juste qui crée un
climat d'emploi fondé sur la dignité et
le respect nous pouvons nous guérir de
l'alzheimer du cancer c'est ça les états
unis c'est ce sont les états unis qui ne
laisse jamais personne derrière
c'est un pays qui n'abandonne jamais
c'est un pays qui ne laisse personne
derrière c'est une grande nation
[Musique]
lens voyez vous c'est un pays composé de
bonnes personnes
c'est ça les états unis d'amérique nous
pouvons faire tout chose lorsqu'on a
travaillé ensemble rien n'a été
impossible concitoyennes vers la fin de
la campagne j'ai commencé à penser à
nîmes qui est très important pour moi et
certainement pour hbo mon fils décédé
c'est quelque chose qu'ils renferment
ma foi ce qui est mon soutien et qui le
soutien des états unis je crois et
j'espère que cela pourra nous donner du
réconfort pour les milliers d'américains
qui ont perdu une personne à cause de la
qu'ovide du virus et donc j'aimerais
espérer que cet hymne ne puisse vous
aider à vous donner du réconfort
voici cet hymne qui dit vous puissiez
vous envoler par les ailes de l'espoir
et que vous puissiez reposer dans les
paumes de ses mains et sur les ailes
d'un angle nous envolons vers dieu et
nos coeurs sont emplis d'espoir nous
avons espoir en les états unis envers
chacun d'entre nous nous avons l'amour
du pays
nous avons faim de cet avenir qui est le
nôtre rêvant donc d'une nation d'une
nation qui est la nôtre d'union de
guérison une
ce sont là les états unis d'amérique
mesdames et messieurs il n'y a jamais eu
jamais eu rien que nous ne puissions
faire nous pouvons faire toutes choses
comme mon grand père m'a dit lorsque
j'ai quitté sa maison lorsque j'étais un
jeune à scranton il m'a dit joe et garde
espoir et ma grand-mère lorsqu'elle
était vivante elle me disait non ne
tient pas à la fois répand ta foi alors
répondez votre foi que dieu vous aime
que dieu vous bénisse que dieu bénisse
l'amérique et que dieu protège nos
enfants et nos troupes
merci
merci encore
[Musique]